Roddy Piper man I mean we could just
talk about him do you guys remember
acting with him when he came in there
was some like method acting
happening when we were off the stage in
the dressing rooms I spent a lot of time
talking to him he was a completely
different person yeah totally he had the
most amazing stories well he told me he
survived a couple plane crashes they
would like take these like little puddle
jumper planes occasionally the engines
would drop out of these things he said
he like survived I think he told me at
least three plane crashes he might have
said five
he had been stabbed by a fan
um or I don't know if you would call
somebody a fan who stabs you but he was
that
hey man big fan
man huge fan and then from that
point forward he had a pistol he had a
pistol with him he would he had a jacket
he always wore a jacket well that's it's
the same jacket he wore on the show yes
that was his jacket that was his jacket
and he showed me where he kept his
pistol which he kept it he still kept it
I miss Roddy I really he was a great
he's great
[Music]